taylor swift stood by lena dunham's side
as she tied the knot with musician
louise felberg it made it a really good
day lena said i do at the union club in
london's soho neighborhood earlier this
month and naturally she wanted her
closest pals by her side including the
shake it off singer who was one of
dunham's bridesmaids long before she was
ever my friend she was my friend in my
head because i was listening to her
while i you know wrote my first film
while i wrote the first season of girls
while i wrote the second season of girls
so she's definitely a soundtrack to many
of my feelings taylor and lena go way
back the actress even made a cameo in
the singer's bad blood music video back
in 2015. we was og like d.o.c remember
that
my tlc
it's clear that their friendship has
stood the test of time vogue shared this
picture of tay all smiles at the
nuptials seated next to 13 reasons why
starred tommy dorfman and comedian jared
carmichael i got my whole squad here
tonight i'm so excited the mag also
shared some beautiful photos from lena
and luis's wedding day which featured
the whimsical decorations and the
newlyweds in action i did it the girls
star also posted this picture on
instagram with her husband writing their
wedding date in the caption september
25th 2021 according to vogue the actress
wore three custom dresses by christopher
kane and get this he designed the
ensembles just two and a half weeks
before the big day
oh come on but it was this dress that
brought lena to tears she walked down
the aisle with a cupcake style look with
long sleeves made out of lace
christopher recalled the moment when she
first tried on the dress telling the mag
she was crying jumping about and dancing
she was like i can't believe i'm so
lucky that was refreshing in august the
newlyweds made their red carpet debut as
a couple they showed up to a screening
of zola at london's sundance film
festival lena rocked a black satin dress
and her man wore a black blazer and
pants with a colorful button-down and
check out this shot of louise kissing
lina's forehead their 35 year old
actress made their relationship
instagram official in june and in july
she shared this video of a visual she
made to her man's music his band's name
is attawalpa
[Music]
in a new york times q a louise revealed
that he met lena on a blind date set up
by a mutual friend explaining quote the
first time we hung out we didn't stop
talking for like eight hours and despite
being together for less than a year he
seems confident in their marriage saying
i think when you know you know i'm going
to sound cheesy but when you find your
soul mate you just know
[Music]